decluttering and living with less is
definitely an important part of
minimalism but owning Less in itself
doesn't Define minimalism
you could very well have a collection or
a large assortment of different items in
your home and still be a minimalist for
example let's say you love snowboarding
in the winter fishing in the summer and
you also love to host parties at your
house and maybe you have pets or a child
so you have lots of different items for
the people in your life and the
activities you enjoy
at the heart of minimalism is intention
this means having the items that you
know you use regularly or that you find
Value in
not just getting rid of items for the
sake of having a minimal home void of
the things that you love
Joshua Becker said it perfectly when he
defined minimalism as the intentional
promotion of the things we most value
and the removal of anything that
distracts us from it
so today I'm going to be sharing with
you 10 minimalism mistakes to avoid not
necessarily as rules but just things
that either I have screwed up myself or
that I wish I had heard about when I was
beginning with minimalism and also be
sure to stick for the bonus at the end
the first one on the list is one that
I'm pretty sure you must have heard
about if you've watched any minimalism
videos but I think it's so important to
reiterate and I'll kind of elaborate on
that as we go through this list and it
is not considering your values before
starting with minimalism the reason that
I think this is so so important is
because your values are different from
your goals so your goal might be to get
out of debt that's an awesome goal there
is nothing wrong with that however that
is different from your value your value
is your reason for why what motivates
you to do that is it because you want to
be able to have more time to spend with
your family or your friends to be more
financially stable so that you can give
or that now you can have time to
volunteer or to do Hobbies or things
that you enjoy so have less stress in
your life so that you can give yourself
more freely to other people what is your
reason for why what is motivating you
knowing that is going to make it so much
easier to make decluttering decisions as
things progress and to face the
challenge challenges of minimalism that
will come along your way
so definitely have goals but also have a
clearly defined why for what it is that
you want out of life and out of this
minimalism experience
number two is something that I am
definitely guilty of and it is
overthinking both purchases and
declutters at the heart of minimalism
lies intentionality and because of this
you kind of have to stretch that
intentionality muscle if you will but it
something that develops over time and in
the process you can kind of easily fall
to extremes where now every single
purchase that you make or every single
thing that you're going to declutter you
overthink things because what if or what
if I don't like this and now I'm going
to regret that I made a purchase because
I'm supposed to be this minimalist and I
shouldn't buy things that I'm gonna only
then declutter later on I totally have
been guilty of doing this and just
overthinking over and over and over
should I purchase this or not I have now
come to be a little bit more forgiving
of myself because I realize that
everything that I either declutter or
that I purchase and made a mistake on if
I goofed it up it's really just a lesson
learned and that helps me to be
forgiving of myself and just let it go
if I made a mistake and I purchased
something that I shouldn't have the
money's gone I cannot get it back
anymore I mean I might be able to sell
it but the damage has already been done
so I might as well learn a lesson from
it and move on mistake number three is a
huge one and it is letting criticisms
either stop you from continuing with
minimalism or letting it be the driving
force for you going to extremes I was
recently chastised by a friend when I
had made a few purchases in her presence
and she basically made some comments
that made it seem as though I'm a
frivolous Shopper like I'm some spoiled
brat that doesn't know how to manage her
money and the day that she told me these
things I cried I didn't know why it
hurts so much and I honestly think that
she was thinking I was having this
breakthrough aha moment and that is why
I was crying and I had to kind of
process this before I could talk to her
about it later but basically to explain
what I was feeling and what was going
through my head it felt like when
somebody does decides that they're going
to be a Christian and they're going to
change their life and they're going to
do all these things to try to be the
best human being that they can be and
they do one thing that upsets someone
and they utter the horrible words
and you call yourself a Christian
these comments are like a stab in the
back they hurt especially when it comes
from a family or friend because you
expect that these are the people that
are going to notice your hard efforts
and your progress that you've made along
the way but often the criticisms from
these individuals are the ones that can
tear us down the most and this is why I
think that number one considering your
values should be the first thing that
you do because if not you might fall
into the Trap of now trying to prove
other people and doing it for other
people and people pleasing rather than
doing it for yourself and your values
after I had the time to really process
the conversation and figure out why this
had hurt me so much I had to come to
terms with the fact that her perception
of me wasn't something that I had to fix
I have definitely been a chronic people
Placer in my life and in the past I
definitely would have wanted to go to
the extreme of well I'll show her but if
I'm doing that then I'm approaching it
from the wrong angle I'm approaching it
from people pleasing from doing
something for someone else or just for
the sake of someone thinking of me in a
particular way and this is why I think
that considering your values and knowing
your reasons for why is really the first
thing that you need to do because you
can fall to those extremes of I'm giving
up what's the point nobody notices my
efforts or well I'll show you I'm gonna
live off a backpack and I'm gonna be
miserable in the process but I'll have
showed you there's really no sense in
trying to prove anything to anyone else
because if we do that it's not changing
our life it may very well change your
life but not in a positive way because
you're not doing it for you anymore
you're doing it to please someone else
so be careful be very careful not to
fall into these traps trap number four
is comparing your progress to other
people I think that to some degree
comparing ourselves is just a natural
human tendency and it can somewhat be
helpful because we can see what other
people are doing that maybe can teach us
ways in which we can improve but it can
so very easily become a trap for us when
we then become frustrated because we are
trying to live someone else's ideal
image of what the perfect life is like I
have a full-time job I have kids and I
have different Hobbies so the particular
items that I have in my home are going
to be different from someone else that
has a different lifestyle and that is
okay learn to embrace your particular
life the particular phase that you are
in and you will be a lot happier for it
rather than trying to constantly fight
against it or to try to obtain the life
that somebody else appears to have
perfectly mistake number five is
decluttering other people's things
without their permission especially if
this is a spouse or if this is somebody
that you're close to whose relationship
it can harm I definitely urge you to
have conversations with these
individuals if you're even thinking
about decluttering something of theirs
because we definitely need to respect
their boundaries and where they are at
in their minimalism Journey if they even
want to start minimalism and this is
where I think that we can sometimes
deter people from it rather than attract
them because if we come at it from an
angle of power and trying to control
it's much more likely that they're not
going to embrace it instead they're
going to try to run from it and abstain
from it we can't force people to change
obviously they they have to want to
change but it's much more likely that if
we have a conversation with them and
actually talk about hey what are your
values what is it that you want out of
life how do you think that maybe having
less could improve your life having
these conversations are going to make it
much more likely that you come at it
from an angle together rather than
somebody against the other number six is
decluttering gifts without having a
conversation with the people whose love
language is gifting a few years back I
read the book the five languages of love
by Gary Chapman and it is definitely a
book that impacted not only my marriage
but just relationships in general
basically what I learned from it is that
different people Express and perceive
love in different ways when I was a
child and even now until adulthood my
parents never gave me gifts even for
Christmas or birthdays I just wasn't
used to that I never once received a box
that was wrapped up with a bow and
because of that gifts aren't really
something that I'm particularly excited
about it's not something that I
particularly care about and so for me if
I give something to someone I'm totally
okay if they decide to give it away to
somebody else or find a different use
for it but for someone whose love
language is gifting they love the
process of picking out the perfect gift
of wrapping it up of putting the little
card on it sending it to you or giving
it to you seeing the smile on your face
for them that is an expression of love
and if you just declutter these items
without having a conversation with them
it might be something that could cause
some tension so if you have somebody in
your life that is a Gift Giver and you
can kind of tell that this is how they
express and perceive love or they become
really happy and excited when you give
them something even if it's something
minimal that might be a clue that you
should have a conversation with them
about the particular lifestyle that you
want to have be open about it and maybe
consider having particular kinds of
gifts that they can give to you so that
way they can still express love in their
language but it's also something that is
respectful of the life that now you are
trying to obtain mistake number seven is
to declutter items that will complicate
your life if you get rid of them you're
all going to think that I'm a total
fraud because Rudy and I have three
vehicles for the two of us he has a
two-seater work van for his construction
job he has a personal vehicle and I have
a personal vehicle buy the perfect ideal
minimal standards we probably wouldn't
even have a car to begin with we would
use a bike or a bus those things are not
options for us and actually I had
considered going down to one vehicle for
the both of us one personal vehicle but
it became very clear that that was not
going to be an option for us when one of
them actually broke down and we had to
take it to the shop it was actually very
stressful to try to scramble to get the
kids from point A to point B because we
both have full-time jobs that have very
sporadic schedules and that two-seater
work van was not going to cut it for the
kids so if you've been considering
minimizing a particular item just to
have less but it's something that might
otherwise complicate your life I would
urge you to reconsider mistake number
eight is to place Aesthetics over people
for the last few months we have had blue
duct tape lining on his bedroom and the
living room it totally goes against the
minimal vibe that I'm trying to go for
as far as the style of our home but I am
completely okay with that I remember a
friend telling me that her mom used to
have this awesome sofa that just looked
pristine but nobody was ever allowed to
sit on it because it just had to look
Immaculate and having this beautiful
fine china but it was always locked away
so that nobody could ever break it I
think ultimately when we're placing such
a high value on Aesthetics and what the
image of the home looks like we're not
really living in it so some days my home
does look a hot horrible mess my kids
and I love building forts on rainy days
that is like our thing and I'm okay if
somebody comes through the door and sees
that hot horrible mess because we are
building experiences we're building
memories on the sofa that is not meant
to be untouched mistake number nine is
to declutter during emotional upsets
just in the same way that you wouldn't
want to text somebody when you're angry
I think the same applies when
decluttering now I'm not saying that
decluttering is always going to be this
happy upbeat emotional experience
sometimes we have baggage and especially
when you're decluttering emotional items
you might realize that you've stashed
away negative emotions as well that can
arise when you're decluttering these
particular items but if you are having a
low emotional day when you're let's say
you've just had a breakup and you're
wondering what the point of life is and
what's the point of it all I would urge
you to reconsider decluttering for
another day when you're more
clear-minded because you may
accidentally declutter something that
you may regret later on mistake number
10 is to declutter items that do
complicate your life but you actually
enjoy the hassle I have about 20 plants
in the home and we have a garden outside
side and in the winter we have to cover
and uncover and there's honestly not a
day that I don't pay attention to at
least one of my plants because they all
have different watering schedules and
different needs but I love the hassle I
love to clean their leaves and I love to
pay attention to them so why would I
declutter something that brings me joy
just because I have a lot of it if you
love to paint for example and you have
tons of supplies relevant to painting by
all means keep them if there's a
particular hobby or a sport that you
love and you have tons of supplies and
equipment for these particular items I
wouldn't declutter those personally
because those items bring me joy I'm
having a use out of them and I don't
want to just declutter and have Barren
walls and be devoid of the things that I
love just for a particular aesthetic or
just to appear like I live a particular
minimal lifestyle I think ultimately it
is about having the things that bring
you the most joy and being intentional
about the things that you allow into
your home and for sticking to the end my
bonus decluttering mistake is to have an
end date in mind I certainly think that
time-specific goals can be super helpful
especially let's say you're moving in a
month and you limit yourself to these
particular amounts of boxes that's an
awesome goal to be able to help you
minimize if you're having a baby soon
and you need to declutter by this
particular date to be able to make space
those goals can definitely help you make
tons of progress but when it comes to
having a specific end date the reality
is that decluttering is never done your
hobbies change your lifestyle will
change your health your phases of your
life will change as well and I think
that rather than trying to rush past
these particular faces it's so much more
freeing when we embrace them and we
allow them to just be so just as I
mentioned the tape example right now
honors and physical therapy and tape is
just going to be all over our floors
that's okay it is a phase and later on
we'll have a different phase so Embrace
whatever phase you are in and don't beat
yourself up if you've made a mistake
with decluttering ultimately minimalism
should be something that is freeing that
adds more joy and value to your life I
hope that by sharing my minimalist
mistakes and things that I wish I had
heard when I was starting off minimalism
has been helpful to you but let me know
what lessons have you learned through
minimalism mistakes I'd love to hear
from you down in the comments below if
you'd like to see more videos on
minimalism be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so that you won't
miss when I post a new video I thank you
so much for watching and I will see you
in the next one bye for now